Barack Obama launching the opening shots
of what's shaping up to be a heated war
of words with President Trump on the
road to the midterms during his return
to the campaign trail in Illinois today
Obama unloading on what he calls the
political darkness of the GOP and his
successor in the White House
he's just capitalizing on resentments
that politicians have been Fanning for
years the politics of division and
resentment and paranoia has
unfortunately found a home in the
Republican Party they're undermining our
alliances cozying up to Russia what
happened to the Republican Party we
can't just put walls up all around
America walls don't keep out threats
like terrorism or disease we do not
pressure the Attorney General or the FBI
to use the criminal justice system as a
cudgel to punish our political opponents
you need to vote because our democracy
depends on the former president taking a
shot at Fox News while criticizing Trump
for his attack on the media it shouldn't
be democratic or republican to say that
we don't threaten the freedom of the
press because they say things or
published stories we don't like
I complained plenty about FoxNews but
you never heard me threaten to shut him
down
or call them enemies of the people
president Trump quickly responding
during his speech in North Dakota yeah
very popular guy here was just
interviewing me you know who I'm talking
about great guy and he said what do you
think of President Obama's speech and I
said I'm sorry I watched it but I fell
asleep I found he's very good very good
for sleeping Gregg which is funny
because President Trump doesn't really
sleep contrasting styles with coming it
was at one o'clock and 2 o'clock yeah
yeah you know President Obama's like
drinking a dozen pina coladas on the
beach it tastes sweet and it looks like
fun then you throw up all night and
remember nothing what I mean he talks
like he was the greatest president you
know he lost 76 House seats and what 15
Senate seats so good luck with having
his support it's not gonna help much and
the problem with all of his digs you
don't have to look very hard to find out
that he's guilty of every single one of
them he talks about Trump targeting the
press James Rosen tapping phones and
emails come on I mean Trump talks that
game but Obama acted it and we talked
about resentment and paranoia that's
that was the progressive wing of the
Democratic Party always the oppressor
versus the oppressed talk about cozying
up to Russia this was the guy who mocked
Mitt Romney because Romney said Russia
was a threat Obama was the one that
mocked him last he said how hard can it
be not to say Nazis are bad Trump sent a
Nazi back that was in the country while
you were president and you couldn't even
say radical Islam there the good news is
Jesse that Barack Obama I can still get
a rise
it's pretty obvious I think Greg put it
very very well I'd only add a few things
it was such a boring speech I had to
watch it and Trump says more in ten
minutes than Obama says in one hour it's
so refreshing this president compared to
the last president where you could drive
a truck right through each sentence but
if you look at the specifics and I'll go
through it again division President
Obama went out and called half the
country bitter clingers he said if you
disagree with me you're racist he says
if you want border security you're
xenophobic and he said if you're against
radical Islam you're in Islamophobic and
trumps are racist
please you've been at paddling around
with Farrakhan and Reverend Wright your
entire life cozying up to Russia I mean
he was whispering sweet nothings in
putin's deputy's ears and said I'll do
whatever you want after the election let
putin run wild don't give me that and
he's saying trump's abusing the attorney
general's office
it was obama's team that spied that
abused FISA that wiretap to their
political enemies so don't give me that
an advice for the Democrats he left that
party in shambles if I was a Democrat
I'd say no thanks that is an interesting
point one that I wanted to get your take
on because President Obama is out there
on the campaign trail because he wants
to gin up the liberal base the Democrats
president Trump is out on the campaign
trail because he wants to gin up the
conservative base but at some point does
President Obama risk overshadowing the
next generation of Democrats because
Barack Obama is not on the ballot he's
never going to be on the ballot again
and when he's not on the ballot
Democrats haven't done that well no but
I think you're in a situation where
President Obama is welcome especially in
states where there are important swing
elections so you're going to see a lot
of Obama in California for example Dana
you'll see him in Illinois he'll make
very targeted strategic trips because I
think they're aware that he is a figure
that the Greg Gutfeld of the world want
to beat up on and say oh it's Obama when
he's but even if he goes to those local
targeted races which I know he's picked
seven in California where the Challenger
is right on the heels of the Republican
there or
ahead yeah but every speech they give is
now national no I think that you have to
also consider he's also doing a lot of
private events raise money and that kind
of thing but I think that what you're
getting in this midterm election is
people are saying you know what we need
all hands on deck and you need the power
of the former president some people
would argue he is the leader of the
Democratic Party until there's an end so
yeah and so I think that they want him
out there and I think they value him
greatly
contrary to what Greg says you know the
Justice Department Jesse don't forget
Jesse you just pick on me all right well
let me get in here but I want you to
listen to what President Trump said I'm
sorry President Obama said about the
economy and the president Trump
responded let's take a listen I'm on the
actions we took during that crisis
returned the economy to healthy growth
and initiated the longest streak of job
creation on record I mentioned all this
just so when you hear how great the
economy is doing right now let's just
remember when this recovery started ok
the recovery did start then but one
thing that's interesting is it was the
tax cut package and the dreg piece that
really put the fuel on the fire to make
it roar it was president Trump's
policies that have taken this economy to
a higher growth Plateau that you have
yet the recovery started in 2009 but
this morning we found out that last
month wages are growing at the fastest
pace in the recovery since 2009 that we
have job growth this year that is
actually so far in the first eight
months on average it's faster than it
was last year that is utterly remarkable
consumer confidence 18-year high factory
growth 14 year high this economy is
firing on all cylinders it's because of
the tax cuts because of the degree
deregulation and not one Democrat voted
for the tax reform the tax cut package
he's on but you know yeah what are you
going to run on deficit he doubled
where's the national debt who President
Obama did
for what bacon so to get us out of a
terrible recession wage growth flat in
this country right now it's flat it's no
disposable income in this country
adjusting for inflation is growing at
two point nine percent that is adjusting
for inflation and it's largely because
of the tax cut and the policies that
pulled us out of that deep recession it
was the Federal Reserve and it was
President Bush who came up with the bank
bailout and the bailout of the auto like
no you don't want to give credit where
credit's due but let's just talk about
the economy is now you see consumer
confidence high and I think that is a
tremendous boost to our economy at the
moment but guess what people are
spending on credit their credit I would
say this about this economy you didn't
build that
supercharged it was the weakest recovery
you want to play now let's have a much
better economy you want to play politics
but there was Steve Forbes I just watch
it on Fox Business know which is a great
network bang away and he said there was
a head coach to let a team to a bunch of
eight Nate records and he was there for
four or five or eight years let's just
say and then you have a new coach come
in in the first year they make the
playoffs that'd be like the old coach
saying oh you know that was all me I did
that no new coach new system a new game
I believe in my heart that President
Obama when these jot these jobs numbers
come out and these economic numbers come
out he's sitting there watching him
going but they're rooting for the
economy to stink to high heaven and I
think that that's a loser that's your
attitude about the way you would feel
Democrats but it's not that's the way
you go after lifted this economy up and
should be a saluted for it's just like
this speech today being hopeful speaking
to our better natures Americans calling
on us to try to save this republic and
instead you went oh didn't know Obama
criticized Fox News yeah but he didn't
try to shut it down which is
Trump is trying to do calling people
Trump's not trying to shut it down what
we're doing here is we're seeing a
pretty decent contrast President Obama
is all eloquence feel-good words no
deeds ever Trump its words or blunt and
rude takes people off but all the deeds
are really good it's the best contrast
you could ever have so you have a smiley
face who gets nothing done or you get a
jerk that gets something why don't you
try telling that to Osama bin Laden why
don't you try telling me how to the
Federal Reserve who didn't say who
rescued their son Rob O'Neal's head it's
a interesting time in turn it's going to
get better data